you know what I like John what do you
like Gregg a non divisive list huh which
is what WatchMojo always delivers
specialty what'd I say your name was
John John that's John that's Greg I'm
Greg we are the real rejects fake ones
we decided to take a more professional
approach from here on out we're trying
to land some hosting gigs it's never
gonna happen let's watch today for a
much top 10 scariest characters in non
horror films because the word Horrors in
here YouTube's like yellow dollar bill
whoa whoa but don't make videos for kids
this is a top from war tier video
requests from a man named Andrew Hayes
who's looking sexier than ever cuz it's
gonna be the best man at a wedding let's
do this yeah good call
at least I think all the rates are
pretty scary so good I never found him
scary I loved him
scary try be scared in person especially
especially when it comes to lightning
attacks but his powers of manipulation
are arguably even more notorious
famously turning the good-nature to an
akin to the dark side
now give them yeah yeah you know what
this your one - yes yes
no to show it go - no I hate this seat
oh thank god
kevin is goodness that's like heaven
that's a yellow bastard there's a great
movie theater experience eighth grade
yeah watch yeah good call this this is a
horror movie though it's like fantasy
horror
I wouldn't call this a non horror movie
III feel like this is usually
categorized there how can you not call
this a [ __ ] oh this was a remember
Washington the theaters terrified what
is pretty freaky is he's scared
yeah especially when he murders the
toons and we come back into the
classroom
I don't know I still would have put a
higher simply not scarier than the Pan's
Labyrinth
get close to you so I can basically get
you anywhere at any time just go oh and
we forgot to mention how it's basically
indestructible shrugging off bullets
explosions and he's coming back it's
from there seven oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
definitely my favorite one's gonna be
Thanos it was a coin
hey guy has a similar hairstyle
oh hell yeah
no one ever calls this movie out I
haven't seen this oh yeah man
the soft-spoken housetops anyone who
wants to jeopardize it this mission is
too important how we not have a face but
the emotionless glow of that red light
is scarier than anything we can imagine
Howl's voice might be the most eerie
thing about him like howdy so chill okay
Phoebe be more than happy to tweet hey I
wanna say Publix we like direct message
yeah yeah go hi hey you up well I
decided in this jump cut in between to
look up Pan's Labyrinth and apparently
it's not categorized as a horror film
and IMDB or Wikipedia so that actually
surprises me because when I went to go
watch it one of the things people told
me was that it's a fantasy drama horror
movie but apparently every category
here's a dark fantasy drama like damn so
watch Mosier take it back I guess you've
earned it
like I know the film's not filled with
horror throughout but there's more than
just that one scene as if it's a pretty
tense movie and there's a lot of scary
monsters and stuff in there and I feel
like you could make the argument because
Guillermo del Toro incorporates horror
and monsters throughout his work true so
it's always in there
I'm always suggesting that for a lot of
stories even if your story is not a
horror film a lot of times if you take a
bit of a horror approach no matter what
the genre is you can just immediately
add some type of tension to it if you're
taking a bit of a horror aesthetic I'm
not even look but just pacing wise tonal
why's it always helps out that's why
there's a lot of scary characters out
there or really intense scenes they feel
like they're out of a horror movie when
they're not like Jurassic Park a lot of
people don't consider that a horror film
but a lot of we do yeah I actually had a
similar reaction to the witch-king of
Angmar because you know Lord the Rings
is another dark fantasy with a lot of
sequences that borrow directly from
horror aesthetics Peter Jackson has a
background in horror so that flavor is
definitely feel like fantasy in general
has an easy in road to horror because it
usually involves mysterious lands
mysterious creatures peril you know and
so all that extra
known creates I think a certain air of
horror I got a few do you do you know
I'd say samuel l.jackson from Jackie
Brown Orville something or another or
Dell or tell oh yes it is ordinal I
remember the first time I watch it's
like Sam Jackson's like kind of funny in
a museum but then it early on in the
movie when he has to take assertiveness
especially with like the Bridget Fonda
character but towards like the finale of
that film socially what goes down with
him and DeNiro he gets pretty scary to
be and also another Tarantino film I
would say is Christoph Waltz an
inglorious basterds
he's a pretty terrifying guy granted
he's kind of like more funny in the last
few minutes of that movie I'd say for a
good chunk of that movie when he's on
screen he's a menace tide I definitely
say him and also say Chris Hemsworth
from bad times at the El Royale oh yeah
there's a lot of buildup to his
character there and then when he has the
chance to steal the show with his screen
presence one of the most tense scenes of
that year was Chris Hemsworth's uh-huh
whole scene where he's taunting
torturing our main characters he's great
in that movie so those are like three
people I'd add on I actually feel like
he could pull a lot of names for this
list but those are the three that
immediately come to mind for me you got
anyone you want to add on well I feel
like you could pull a bunch from
Tarantino because both his character
Steven and Django and hang is pretty
freaking also Calvin Candie gets pretty
horrifying sure especially during the
dinner scene when you know he loses his
[ __ ] just the level of intensity is
pretty gnarly what about the girl from
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
oh yeah nurse rancette imagine it was a
nurse hatchet Nurse Ratched
you know same difference miss ratchet I
think is terrifying that's not a horror
film mmm
that stand is true the thing with
Palpatine for me is yes he's maniacal
he's gleeful everything about him
readings of a horror villain but I've
never really found him scary what he's
doing can be scary in terms of the
context for what the characters are
receiving from him I've always been
really entertained and really amused by
him but I've never particularly found
him scary I might be in the minority on
that though
and is a beloved character I just never
really associated him as a scary villain
well I think that now that rise of
Skywalker is out and it's been confirmed
that he procreated with somebody that
really clinches the terror because then
you have to think about palps having sex
and you just don't want to do that you
know
so I think that earns the spot might as
well also I have to agree with penguin
from Batman Returns that movie terrified
me when I was a kid I've grown to really
love that film I saw it again a couple
of years ago and when I look at it more
as like a Tim Burton movie as opposed to
a Batman movie I really do like it and
out of those films from the 90s of
Batman that's actually my favorite one I
do prefer the Jack Nicholson one but
penguin is terrifying that fell I was
really haunted by the whole biting the
nose thing like factly the kids were
gonna go watch it I thought that's a
little kid who's so freakin scared what
he did that just the image oh speaking
of other you know kind of films like
that Coraline came to my mind the puppet
mom is pretty freaky yeah that's another
dark fantasy and I think that was one of
those movies that came out where people
were like this is gonna be too freaky
for children yeah
ass Prince Kevin is on this list yeah I
would see him more as an honorable
mention than one of the top ten I think
it's because when I first saw it I was
really distracted by the fact it was
Elijah Wood hmm because Lord of the
Rings had just come out and all the time
like is Elijah Wood it's a lot I'm
really distracted by the fact that it's
Elijah Wood I mean yeah it is
technically like a scary character but
he's barely in the movie - yeah a
presence I really like just hit Kevin in
the movie but yeah for the short amount
of time he's on screen I am surprised
that he landed in the middle of this
list and not maybe it's like the 10 spot
or something bad or a gallon or we'll
mention a judge doom sure well you see I
confession I didn't see Roger Rabbit
until a year ago and I did enjoy it a
lot I was surprised by how adult it is
mm-hmm
it's like toon characters through how
like famous two characters are really
prevalent in that felt a big deal it's
kind of a mature movie like the themes
of murder or a lot of sexual stuff -
kids love Bob Hoskins I was surprised by
that and I will say that yeah in terms
of like watching it as a child I can
imagine the judge doom character beans
the scene where I thought it was
menacing the most was when he murders
one of the tunes when he's introducing
the toxic waste a bad thing that he has
that he slowly puts one in and takes a
name for it and I can't remember off the
top of my head it's like goo but not
that seam was the part I was scared like
all the other animation stuff it was
more fascinated by I could see from a
child perspective how scary
he still unnerves me when he comes back
in his cartoon form in the finale like
that whole ending bit for him yeah I
still find pretty obscure me and
uncomfortable the t1000 a I felt like
this list would include Arnold from
Terminator or t1000 from t2 but I think
there's a much bigger argument to be
made that Terminator 1 is a horror movie
it's basically a slasher movie with a
robot yeah t2 has its dark undertones
and its Menace that is definitely
prevalent but it's more of a sci-fi
action film and the t1000 in that movie
is really scary it's pretty impressive
how he managed to out do Arnold in terms
of being scary yeah you know like did
have the villain of Arnold seats use
that in the matrix yeah this Agent Smith
you can say - what about the incinerator
from Toy Story 3 sure weirdly the one I
think people might have a bit of a gripe
with could be Heath Ledger's Joker it's
like is he actually scary my eyes I
thought he was a scary villain I thought
that was part of the fun of watching him
is that he is really funny
he is really clever but I did find him
also to be really scary course all these
lists are subjective but I'm just glad
he's on here because he's Heath Ledger's
The Joker Oh just thought of another one
up Jude Law from roadtrip
huh I think is a pretty creepy ass
villain and definitely not a horror
movie but he's great he's great in that
movie have you guys seen it
you guys haven't seen you should watch
it how about Vincent D'Onofrio men in
black hey I mean like he's funny but
also like just the more he rots and the
worse he looks in physical human form I
do think he's actually kind of unnerving
antosha gore that's a no-brainer right
there mmm-hmm I'm surprised they flashed
to the sergeant from Full Metal Jacket
and he's not on his list I know even as
an honorable mentioned earlier me that's
his character well he was a real drill
sergeant and they put him in there and
then he made a career playing through
bands or playing takes on that like
Texas Chainsaw Massacre
yeah but I'm surprised on the list he's
totally terrifying in that movie is Hal
9000 that's a no-brainer
I haven't even seen 2001 a Space Odyssey
had tickets to watch it on the IMAX
re-released something really important
came up and I had to return my ticket
why would you read format a film an IMAX
format and only put it out for a week I
doesn't make any sense yeah it seems
like you'd get your investments worth
but maybe they don't think that the kids
today are gonna turn out for 2001 I
couldn't go back as their sole Bauer's
pet that's why you know maybe they
figured that all of the kids will come
in this five-day window and I don't want
to go to an IMAX screen sitting at the
front row ah painful that would be enjoy
make that famous montage immersive and I
know I was colors joking about him being
number one on this list but I think that
I was pre qualify as least an honorable
mention sure he's scary in a stakes way
his demeanor when he's just chilling
isn't that scary but you know that's
fair you know it was a fair way to play
cuz we do see him like chillin and just
like in his element so to speak you know
not menacing an Avenger mm-hmm anybody
else any other bright idea
yeah I do got one Sharon Stone in Basic
Instinct
thriller though you're getting close gee
you're getting out a horror movie yeah
it's just thrilling yeah she's pretty
scary in that film you don't know when
Scarface Giovanni Ribisi and Ted huff is
pretty freaky and like his level of
commitment is unsettling in and of
itself you know this might be an odd
pick any name into the characters in the
movie but in Apocalypto have you seen
that no in Apocalypto there's this
really sinister villain there he's not
like head honcho of the group I remember
the theatres when there was a showdown
with him everyone applauded and this was
during when people were hating Mel
Gibson Mel Gibson just in a real life
hey hey sorry let it go let it go Chris
Brown long ago Kanye West
what villain do you think should be on
this list leave a comment below
subscribe to watchmojo.com overlay and
Andrew our loyal patronage act thank you
so much for requesting this dude Andrew
is getting fit and in shape because he's
gonna be the best man at the wedding
now as best man you got to make sure you
take the groom on a crazy wild bachelor
party you live in the East Coast so you
better you better but also it's good
that you're getting in shape looking bit
looking sharp make sure you get a really
nice suit for the wedding because
there's always the ladies looking at the
single best man believe me I wouldn't
know is a never been best manage of
wedding but I think that's how it goes
and you got to take advantage of that
plus if you were your Wolverine hat like
that's gonna bring everybody in because
there's nothing sexier than a man in a
suit with a comic-book hat on yeah he
doesn't care
yeah he's edge he's too cool for this
ceremony or he just looked like a
disrespectful Jack yes but you know it
really takes it out I don't wear that